hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well one of the
central aspects of John Paul starts
short essay existentialism is a humanism
that that many readers find confusing or
difficult to wrap their heads around
is this universalism that he insists
upon over and over and over again that
seems to go in some respects against
some of the other things that he's
saying about existentialism and us being
on our own as individuals but reft of
any sort of pre given values or
arrangement or human nature that we can
rely upon Sartre will tell us that well
here's how he phrases it when a person
is responsible for themself we do not
mean only that they are responsible for
their own individuality but that they
are responsible for all humanity that
that's a very big statement there but
it's needed to ground any sort of
existentialist ethics that's going to be
more than just an individualistic
seeking of meaning or value or perhaps
even just pleasure on the other hand
once people start hearing things like
that if they've had a little bit of
history of philosophy or a little bit of
a background they immediately see
connections with somebody else who spoke
in very universal terms and that is a
monument with his cat
Oracle imperative the forced formulation
of which runs that we should always act
upon the maximum that we can will at the
same time to be a universal law of
nature so we have to say you know what
if everyone did this you know then you
know you decide whether it's moral or
immoral that looks very similar to what
start is doing so people hear that and
they're like well I don't see much of
Kant's in the rest of this as a matter
of fact the only philosopher who he
actually mentions quite positively in
this respect is Descartes and how does
that fit in so there's there's some
problems with this that that seemingly
arise and generate confusion there's a
lot that he says about this in
existentialism is a humanism and I've
broken it down into four main points
that we should think about the first is
that he insists that when we choose we
choose for all humanity we don't just
choose for ourselves we are choosing for
humanity writ large we are choosing in a
genuinely universal way so he tells us
as I just brought up we are in fact
responsible not just for ourselves that
is we not only have to give an account
for ourselves we are responsible for all
humanity we are responsible for
everybody who's going to be a human
being and everybody who is and so he
goes out a little bit more you know in
the same section and he says when we say
that a person chooses their own self and
I'm changing the language here to make
it a little bit more gender-neutral and
inclusive we mean that every one of us
does likewise but we also mean that in
making this choice we also choose all
humans we doesn't just say we choose for
all humans we choose all people there's
there's a vital difference there he says
in creating the person that we want to
be there's not a single one of our acts
which is not at the same time create an
image of humanity as we think humanity
ought to be so we choose
just the individual act we choose to be
the kind of person who engages in that
act and he gives lots of examples in the
determinant circumstances that I met I
could choose to be a trade unionist over
here we would say choose to join the
union or not or to be a supporter of the
Union or to be a strikebreaker and what
did I choose that I'm not just choosing
for myself and saying well in my
circumstances I have to do this but I
you know I know that in other
circumstances the right thing to do
would be this we're saying no no this is
the the model of human being that I am
endorsing that I am putting forth in my
own actions if I choose to be a coward I
am choosing that humanity should be
cowards or cowardly or coward like if
I'm choosing to be fair and just I'm
choosing that for Humanity and notice
that this is a little bit different than
Kant doesn't think that we can actually
choose something bad something where
there's a bit of you know perversion or
corruption or or something wrong with it
right we can't choose that consistently
we can only choose that it is an
exception for ourselves we're saying
everybody else should behave this way
but I get to be a complete bastard over
here or I get to bend the rules or I get
to do things differently for myself
Sartre is saying when you endorse that
you're going to be the kind of person
who abuses a child you are endorsing
that that is what humanity ought to look
like I'm in a certain respect it's a
little bit more not just open-ended but
dangerous and horrific because you know
think about the people that Sartre was
opposing at the time the Nazis are
choosing for all humanity just as much
as are the resistance in his time so he
says to choose that to be this or that
is to affirm at the same time the value
of what it is that we choose we always
choose the good and nothing can be good
for us without being good for all and he
says if existence precedes essence and
if we grant that we exist in
fashion our image at 1:00 in the same
time this image is valid for everyone
and for our whole age so our
responsibility is much greater than we
might have supposed because it extends
to all humanity he's not saying that
every choice is actually good it in a
full sense but he's saying that this is
the pit of freedom that we look into
nothing actually determines whether I'm
going to be a good guy or a bad guy
other than the fact that I choose that
and in doing so I'm endorsing that for
all humanity so I had this incredible
sort of weight upon my shoulders he goes
on and he talks about there's a little
bit later the universe the universality
of humanity right and he says that what
is this universality it's not that there
is actually some sort of pre given human
essence that all of us have I mean you
could say well what about genetics what
about the fact that we all carry
basically the same DNA true that's not
essence as Sartre is talking about here
because we are not merely our genetic
code or the expression of that in this
body we are what we choose to do with
that so there is no determinism for
Sartre that actually compels us to make
the choices that we are there's no human
essence pre-given but he does say that
there is something that is universal to
humanity says if it's impossible to find
in every human being some universal
essence which would be human nature
there does exist a universal human
condition and he says by condition the
thinkers of today mean more or less the
opéra limits which outline human beings
fundamental situation in the universe
historical situations vary a person may
be born a slave in a pagan society or a
feudal lord or a proletarian what
doesn't vary what is invariant as we
could say is the necessity for him to
exist in the world
to be at work there to be there in the
midst of other people and to be mortal
there he says these are not objective or
subjective they have an objective and a
subjective side objectively they're
found everywhere and a recognizable
everywhere subjective because they're
lived and are nothing if a human being
does not live them so all of us face
certain basic existential conditions you
can say for example having to die for
example having to deal with other people
for example having to work in some sort
of sense right now what we do with that
that is actually up to us we decide as
Sartre within says within our
circumstances he says that you know
every configuration and it gives another
examples can be understood by somebody
from a different place can be understood
means that by virtue of a situation they
can imagine they can push themselves to
their limits and reconstitute within
themselves the configurations of others
every configuration has a certain
universality so he says this
universality of human being is not given
it is perpetually being made we every
one of us is choosing what it means to
be a human being in that sense and not
just for ourselves but for others within
these circumstances how do we respond to
circumstances how do we deal with
fundamental existential you could call
them conditions of what it means to be
human so he goes on and he he also talks
at several points about the possibility
of concealing this situation from
oneself saying oh I don't desire decide
for everybody I only decide for myself
if you're gonna ask me what if everyone
were to do as I do
not a problem not everybody does and
there's all sorts of very
creations on this it can be the person
who thinks of themself as high IQs like
the mere mortals couldn't understand
what I'm choosing to do right although
they're not very bright when it comes to
the limitations of IQ tests right or
they're wilfully blinding themselves to
it because they happen to get a high
score at one point in time there's also
the criminal who says well obviously not
everybody's going to do as I do that's
very similar to Kant's wanting to make
an exception for oneself but Sartre says
that everybody who's doing something
like that who's saying oh not everybody
could do or not everybody is doing as I
do is kind of not just missing the point
but willfully obscuring the point
because they do bear that same
responsibility they are trying to evade
it there's a certain dishonesty in their
comportment within the world that is
driving that response on their part and
not surprising because it's difficult to
bear this responsibility especially if
you're acting like a jerk and you
realize you're acting like a jerk and
here we come to the fourth point Sartre
says that we can actually pass judgment
upon others in the uses that they make
of their freedom within the human
condition and you might say well how can
you do that you've just said that
everybody sort of decides for themselves
and they decide for all humanity yes yes
and what that means is being responsible
to another which means they can engage
in judgment upon you not only can we
engage in judgment upon them everybody
else can engage in judgment upon us they
can decide that we did the wrong thing
in history and that we were actually a
bunch of bastards who lied to ourselves
and did awful things to other human
beings and that we should have chosen
differently that is a possibility
because they are equally deciding what
humanity will be and they do that in
that judgment so judgment can be passed
and Sartre here is going to talk about
two different modalities of judgment he
says first one can judge and this is not
a judgment of value but a logical
judgment that certain choices are based
error and others on truth what does he
mean there well if we've defined human
situations as a free choice with no
excuses and no recourse then anybody who
takes refuge behind excuses excuses of
hope a shin made me do it my anger my
love my despondency whatever it happens
to be every person who sets up a
determinism he says is dishonest why
because they are lying to themselves and
lying to others and lying to the world
about the fact that they could have
chosen differently they're even lying to
themselves about the fact that they've
imposed this explanation or excuse out
there in the world and somebody could
say well how are you gonna prevent that
Sartre
why can't somebody choose themselves
dishonestly and he says well that's fine
I'm not required to pass moral judgment
upon them but I can define dishonesty as
an error you cannot help considering the
truth of the matter dishonesty is
obviously a falsehood because it belies
the complete freedom of involvement he
says I maintain there's also dishonesty
if I choose to state that certain values
exist prior to me it's self
contradictory for me to want them and at
the same time state they're imposed upon
me what if somebody says to me what if I
want to be dishonest and Sartre says
knock yourself out buddy but you're
gonna be dishonest and if you want to
hide that from yourself you're doubly
dishonest and I'll call you on it so
this is not yet getting to a sort of
moral judgment but there's a prior to
that judgement about consistency it's
also possible to pass a moral judgment
upon other people and their choices he
says when I declare that freedom and
every concrete circumstance can have no
other aim than to want itself then you
know this this becomes the basis of
values that doesn't mean that he wants
it in the abstract it means that the
ultimate meaning of the acts of honest
people is the quest for freedom as such
our commitment to certain concrete goals
should be furthering that
and if it isn't then we have to make a
decision are we going to go along with
that make a ton of money or being you
know a communist or a revolutionary or
being whatever else it happens to be or
are we gonna say well I have to go where
freedom you know requires me to go
whatever that freedom happens to look
like which am I going to choose for all
humanity and he says we can we can judge
people for that so he says that freedom
is the definition of human being does
not depend on others but as soon as
there's involvement I'm obliged to want
others to have freedom at the same time
that I want my own freedom I can take
freedom as my goal only if I take that
of others as a goal of well as goal as
well so when I've recognized that you
know humans are free beings I have at
the same time recognized that I need to
want the freedom of others so if I'm
hiding from myself the fact that I'm
actually repressing the freedom of
others are depriving them of freedom
then moral judgment can certainly be
passed on me as a matter of fact moral
judgment can be passed on anybody within
this scheme right but it's passed on the
basis that through my actions through my
words through what it is that I choose
how I prioritize the uses that I make of
my freedom
I am sending a message about how
humanity ought to be that message can be
called into question by others we live
in a world of heterogeneity you can say
when it comes to values so this is what
Sartre means by the connection between
choice and responsibility and this
universalization that takes place that
doesn't stem from a human essence but
rather from a human condition and this
being the conditions of the exercise of
our freedom
you